over the weekend in Iowa
failed former president Donald Trump
gave a number of speeches in different
parts of the state of Iowa and early
state in the primary process and an
important state he gave a speech in
Urbandale he gave a speech in Des Moines
he gave a speech in Grimes and
potentially others as well uh now I mean
it's almost automatically satirical
the crowd chanting USA when Trump enters
[Applause]
well I want to thank you this was a
little bit of a surprise for you I heard
but there you go Trump's surprising the
crowd and the crowd chanting USA one of
the claims Trump made during these
events was that we need to bring
religion back into the country now that
may come as a surprise to those who
realize not only has religion not left
the country we still have religious
influence in Government at the state and
federal level you regularly hear
religious arguments made during Civil
policy debates when it comes to abortion
or gay marriage or whatever the case may
be many of us wondering why is there so
much religion given that we're supposed
to have separation of church and state
Trump says we have to bring religion
back and we have to bring religion back
into our country because that's
something that's
that's something that is as you know
it's under uh it's under attack right a
lot of us are under attack and we uh
We're not gonna we're gonna win we're
gonna win big we're gonna win bigger
than ever before just uh yep bigger than
ever before we're going to bring
religion back people wondering where did
it go it seems to be very front and
center a hilarious moment Fox News
dipped into Trump's speeches at one
point and right when uh anchor Harris
Faulkner cuts to Trump in Urbandale Iowa
Trump is defending the January 6 rioters
this is always a risk if you cut into a
live Trump speech he could be defending
anyone and in this particular case fox
goes over and Trump is defending the
rioters Trump is speaking at the West
Side conservative breakfast in Urbandale
Iowa right now let's watch what happens
to these people and then you look at
what they've done to the January six
people they've destroyed them and
destroyed their lives and a lot of them
didn't even go into the building it was
a disgrace what's going on that is it
whoops let's cut away does disgrace
that's that's going to go down in
history ultimately and Ashley Babbitt
was killed shot by uh in my opinion a
rogue cop he had no business doing that
he shot her shot unarmed and actually
people say she was trying to hold back
the people that were pushing her forward
she was a good Samaritan there I mean of
course the investigation into that
shooting didn't find any of that
evidence but she was a good Samaritan
suddenly the officer was in the wrong
say the always defend the police people
Ashley Babbitt was the one that was
killed she was the one that was killed
and uh they like to say five people
that's the truth is and there will
happen to be somebody else also in
addition to Ashley but Ashley Babbitt
was a big supporter of everybody in this
room and there you go by every account
she was an incredible person and a great
Patriot and he shot her like just like
he had no problem and then yeah so not
exactly the best moment for Fox News to
care Trump speech Trump then complained
many people who used the term woke can't
Define it now I want you to remember
this moment because we're going to get
back to that a little bit later on a
very big on on school choice can you
imagine we even have to talk about
parental control and having parents
basically having parents get involved we
have school systems that don't even want
to talk to the parents about their
children and you talk about changing
gender and things where the child can
make a choice and the child can be
unbelievably young the country has gone
sick it's gone sick and I don't like the
term well because I hear woke woke woke
you know it's like just a term that used
half the people can't even Define it
they don't know what it is right but you
look at these things like women getting
you know competed with with you know men
that were men he barely is able to keep
the sentence going and our men and
they're out there swimming and setting
records you see the records that are
being broken
records that lasted for 19 years of
being broken by you know 30 seconds
they're trying to win by a sixteenth of
a second for in swimming on one of the
events a sixteenth of a second they're
trying to win for years
and a guy comes along and breaks the
record by you know numbers that will
never be broken all right so you get it
just over transphobia confusion and
disorientation there
um someone and this was kind of a funny
moment someone in the crowd praised the
governor of Iowa Kim Reynolds and Trump
is just so insecure that he immediately
has to say hey it was thanks to me that
she won and uh they ought to look at his
past record by the way take a look at
his past record
Kim Reynolds for governor of Iowa
foreign
I hate to say it without me you know she
was not going to win you know that right
I gave you a couple of them without me
they wouldn't have won uh but uh it's me
me it can't just be praised for someone
else who's doing a good job and then um
lastly here someone in the crowd asks
Trump hey when you become president day
one you know this growing list of day
one promises that are never done uh what
are you gonna do to bring back respect
for law enforcement in this country uh
the Mueller report uh the fake dossier
how about the dossier which was written
up by the Democrats all fake stuff and
uh a disgusting thing and I had to go
through a long time and still we did
more than just about any president in
history with all of that stuff on my
shoulders they tell me oh I was a
Russian agent okay I was a Russian agent
I used to say first I thought they were
kidding when I heard that I said yo
that's sort of funny I didn't know what
the hell I hadn't even spoken to anybody
in Russia you know they went through
five million phone calls and I didn't
make one call to Russia that was a
little bit bad but they didn't denounce
that they didn't talk about that totally
unintelligible word salad when asked
about respect for law enforcement we
have a very very corrupt system and it's
got to be and we need from the top we
need great people we need heads of the
FBI we need heads of the uh the top
people at the Department of Justice
right this is there you go so uh unable
to answer even a single question and now
we go to maybe the most interesting
moment from all of Trump's Iowa speeches
we've talked on the show about how
internet service providers have been
logging everything their customers do
online and selling that data tech
companies use trackers in websites and
apps to collect your data you can Shield
yourself from all of it by using a VPN
every time you connect to the internet
the VPN I use is private internet access
it's the only VPN that has proven
multiple times in court they do not log
your activity our sponsor private
internet access hides my IP address
prevents big Tech from being able to
paint a picture of who I am and what I
do online and it works for all of your
favorite streaming platforms like
Netflix and Hulu to access shows and
movies normally only available in other
countries it's one of the only vpns that
works for peer-to-peer file sharing and
the best part is you can protect
unlimited devices with just one account
going online without private internet
access is like leaving your phone
unattended in a crowded room anyone can
just take a glance my audience gets 83
percent off that's just 203 a month plus
four extra months for free go to
piavpn.com Pacman the link is down below